[Music]
it's giving bestie I don't understand
how you cannot fan girl about that well
everyone was Fanning out about Taylor
Swift at Monday's I Heart Radio Music
Awards but Taylor wasn't just everyone's
BFF at the show she also took home top
honors receiving the innovator award but
I think the coolest ideas or moves or
choices are the new ones the ones that
set a new precedent after accepting her
award Taylor headed backstage where this
moment happened
girl
[Music]
Dean Lenny Kravitz the night's host
giving off bestie Vibes as they
complement each other's outfits really
good I just said okay
I was just inspired
and speaking of inspired looks Flavor
Flav definitely took a note from Taylor
sporting this shirt with lyrics from her
song Willow
[Music]
I come back stronger than a 90s Trend I
love me some Taylor Swift man I always
did you know what I'm saying I don't
even I can't if it's something I tell
her things like that blades night was
made when he finally got to meet Taylor
check him out all smiles in this selfie
oh man I'm crazy excited Taylor also got
in some quality time with ice spice the
rapper looking Overjoyed presented tay
with the song of the year award for
anti-hero I really appreciate it
as they exited the stage the two
embraced in a hug soon after internet
investigators uncovered this yep I
spikes hit Taylor with a follow on IG
during the show yep but it was really
later in the night Taylor caught up with
Phoebe Bridgers one of her opening acts
on the heiress tour and a long time pal
it's a group of friends that are so cool
and when it was time to present her with
the innovator of the Year award Phoebe
gave the most heartfelt speech opening
up about how Taylor inspired her to tell
the truth as a young songwriter as I
grew up so did Taylor and so did her
songs
gradually my song started to suck less
because instead of trying to sound
interesting I just started telling the
truth
Taylor has always told the truth
following Phoebe's intro Taylor's
industry friends like Dolly Parton
Justin Timberlake Selena Gomez and Ed
Sheeran surprised her with video
messages being a role model I don't
think that's something you sign up for I
just think it's something you inherently
have inside of you and I think that's
Taylor her stories are her songs and I
think that is the new Norm it's one of
those friendships where it the
Friendship doesn't move even when life
moves it's nice to have someone who has
the same kind of stresses and and and
sort of
challenges in life you know and during
her acceptance speech Taylor shared her
appreciation for all the love and threw
in some signature Taylor little inspo
for her fans I really really want
everyone to know especially young people
that
the hundreds
or thousands of dumb ideas that I've had
are what led me to my good ideas you
have to give yourself permission to fail
foreign
[Music]